[Music]
this week we've got robo bees a live
sushi and tall man failed taken away
there for me I gotta do it I'm sorry
is it cuz bees are going it's extinct
and then if they die then we all die
yeah eventually I know I wasn't being
exaggerated honeybee problem there is we
gotta save up bees yeah they're not
[ __ ] they're not funny and they're
getting sick
yeah you're not pollinating like what
makes bees [ __ ] what turns them on yeah
what's going on is it bugging like the
Sun patterned or some [ __ ] and they have
a little bee dance they know how to make
you back to the flower they [ __ ] each
other in the flower that's wrong man
yeah I'm like a sixteen step [ __ ] bad
I think most bees are sparrows almost I
think so if it's just one queen bee I
think it's just one yeah Queen Bee not
all these [ __ ] babies popping up all
these babies Wetherby rules do we know
yeah who's the be gigolo that's [ __ ]
the queen bee oh dang I want to be a
queen is there just one that's the queen
around I thought the Queen around what
does that mean like the pastor around
like the everyone gets the [ __ ] yeah
everyone gets a turn I think you know
there was a gigolo bees scientist here
he's like all the other pastor around
them I know we should bring up
professional lens and I think like like
set the record straight then we wouldn't
be just kidding these no but we should
get a guy and hit him here
no no we should sit him here and then
see how long he'll stay here before he
just [ __ ] leave
dr. drew you know what I mean like he
knows how to [ __ ] around but you know I
don't want no [ __ ] nerds in our group
I'll beat the [ __ ] out of them just
kidding why do they [ __ ] the real quick
though is it like doggy style is it like
one on top of it like missionary
I think it's doggy stuff it's all B's
[ __ ] doggy stuff Hey sure hi but then
the queen bee gets but well I think her
mouth is getting [ __ ] too
just type in be [ __ ] and we can
figure like you can after this once and
for all
is it doggy style and then also her
mouth to it why I hope not that's always
that's what it is
yeah but what if these things are what
the Stinger and then it is doggy style
is right ya know with the class I've
seen before three because he told me
he's like hey look I can't come unless
you play up my button he's a okay oh my
god there's two in one
like they're like the [ __ ] with the
shot and that's at these whole job use
entire zone three that's fine too
that's fine you want to be the queen bee
girl no but it takes three to me they
can't just do - that's a demo that's
what made you look like which one
another better one good eye watch didn't
like there's something about that feels
really warm
that's a note thank you me that's it
would there's these Japanese scientists
that have developed a remotely
controlled drone the size of a dragonfly
which is able to pollinate so they're
calling these Robo bees which is the
black bear episode coming to life
and I think it's dope that it's from
Japanese people cuz they probably just
watched the same video we did if the
devil's threesome turned them on and
they're like we can't have these
beautiful creatures go extinct they love
section over there that's a liar yeah I
can I can second that as a Japanese
everything motivates yes are you extra
warning for no reason yeah how does a
Japanese man here for no reason
it just happens I was just born horny do
you look like a like a bowl of fruit and
you like need to [ __ ] some is anything
No maybe yeah if it looks like a titty
yeah that's the mean that's dope though
no it's okay well they have this episode
you commander getting high and then you
could go into people's brains through
their nose or ears and then you could
kill them I beat you to the punch
oh I didn't see that targeted
assassinations I remember that one yeah
and then they actually mentioning that
same thing in this article too that
they're saying like that is something to
be concerned about that there is a
possibility that these bees can get
hacked what are you gonna do with a hack
to be man whoa Justin you could target
to kill somebody they have a stinger
that could like do that I don't know
good crawl into your nose and then go
into your brain like a specific a
specific part of your brain that makes
your where you go through ears just a
cavity I don't think it like literally
like is open to your brain because I
wouldn't mean your brain is open to the
world like we did this one JK news
episode where this woman she kept having
a runny nose and it turns out it was her
brain fluid leaking out oh that's just
like I think something wrong with her
right cuz I don't think your brain is
literally open to the sinuses cuz they
need to be breathing on to your brain
interns over there nothing about the
fluid yeah
and it's between the brain and your
skull but I think and that's where kind
of like this exchange of blood nutrients
my grandpa like explaining something to
me
when I was with your grandma is like
love like 1945 47 scares you like Jesus
right yeah well is that better or is it
better for him to just push through
while he's like yeah good calm these be
though they're saying that they can
program them to have a pretty much like
sort of a digital map of every single
flower and petal like every like super
detailed map to the point where these
drones can go and pollinate each flower
why are we where yeah that's this tiny
this is not scary this is dope you
didn't light cameras on it no [ __ ]
stingers no like that if it just
literally all I can do is pollinate good
right it's gonna save a lot kind of you
like hey look let's not on the bees why
would comfortable as long as they have
nice round stingers not sure the
Japanese people are listening to this
now and they're like oh [ __ ] we [ __ ]
up yeah this thing that dude [ __ ]
break every finger now by him was like
oh man where's David I'm gonna click on
the next one
like everybody watches this thing I love
it alright for our next story there was
this video that went viral of this sushi
in Japan that was not dead it was very
much alive on those guys plates I
thought that was yeah normal
I thought the hell yeah they have stuff
like that right well apparently not this
is a clam a clam surf clam so but by the
way that they are reporting this it's
not supposed to be like we seem natural
I love it I know nothing about it
oh damn is twitching he's like where's
the water
where's my mom where's my dad it's taken
out of the shell though I think they're
speaking Chinese this one was kind of
dark to me yeah it's like to struggle
for life like we hate sushi sure that
just looks it looks like something
helpless is my thing that it's so
helpless it's like damn yeah what the
[ __ ] even is is an organ usually as soon
as the chef puts it down you're supposed
to put your mouth you missed that whole
part yeah and then it's wiggling a mouth
you just look around like yep it's still
alive wait with regular sushi yeah when
they pass it to you like that yeah it's
supposed to be a it's kind of like a
gimmick experience thing yeah I've had
like the delay octopus or squid or one
of those how's that I mean it was an
experience but they chopped it up so
it's not a lie was just like the rigor
mortis of it that was kind of scary
though cuz we ate it in Korea yeah and
then it was literally a lot like here's
a fish tank they grab that [ __ ]
out yeah put it right here and then
chopped it up it was a lot [ __ ]
scissors like and then the like baby
octopus is like crawling on a
[ __ ] Oh like 101 got on the table and it
was like trying to leave and she grabbed
it back up but she's like just chopping
it up and I was like damn if I saw that
I probably wouldn't have even it but
they chopped it up in the back and then
they bring it already in little pieces
and it's just like wiggling so I'm like
disconnected from the fact that it was
alive it reminded me of like when my
cousin used to cut the eyes of snails
when it started raining wait what
like with scissors yeah back into his
childhood yeah he's like he used to cut
the eyes of all when it was rainy my
cousin was like I can't wait to go
outside and then he would drag me out
when we would have a bottle of salt and
he would bring his scissors out and then
he would just be sitting there cutting
the [ __ ] eyes of every single snail
and then he would make me throw salt on
them I understand you so much located is
he Monterey Park go figure
really Asian kid uh primo you know like
the instant noodles the Shannara and
it's like a bread pack when it was
raining we would purposely go in the
kitchen and take out the seasoning pack
and sprinkle it on snails and you would
see it foam up and it was like the
finest in it that's horrible yeah it is
horrible you can't judge I was for us
you were guilty by association
I know you're horrible I looked up to
him but yeah there's things like they
get fish right you'll see the fish in
the fish tank and indel they'll get it
and then they'll fillet it while the
fish is alive and then so the fish is on
your plate filleted and it's twitching
while there's pieces of meat right there
and then that's kind of like a show it's
not really there's no emotional
attachment that sounds like a you and
dog fest because it was like well I
think it comes from like way back in the
day right before refrigeration that the
SF and it was to show how fresh it would
be yeah cuz they'll get a fish out of
the bucket and they'll cut the fish out
of the bucket immediately and in its
fresh versus like now it shouldn't still
be alive and like still dying
that I can't hang with it yeah yeah yeah
it's on my plate and it's still wiggling
could chop the head off in front of me
yeah I see and I'm talking about not
even maybe maybe even like 10 years ago
they thought that fish didn't have any
like feeling of pain like that's a new
discovering so really they just found
that the [ __ ] plants have feeling a
pain so it's about to get real [ __ ]
trans fight they go like they fight over
each other with roots oh yeah yeah yeah
and then they speak to each other I
don't know about that anything man
pretty much yeah if you want to harm if
you don't wanna hurt anything that can
feel pain exactly don't even eat no bean
didn't eat rice I guess or boil it first
I don't think it's a problem with eating
live things it's like make sure it's
dead like when you see a deer that got
hit by a truck shoot them on the [ __ ]
it's dead then we'll eat it whatever a
dozen I like it's alive like twitching
and you're like enjoying they're like
huh they do cut the heads off of their
fish yeah and then so it is dead but
then it's I don't know so it's just like
the Leighton effects of like the nerves
okay yeah the rhythm work I don't know
when I see fish it's the same as plants
to me maybe a mammal would make me feel
different like if it was a only if it's
cute
yeah if it was like a [ __ ] skunk and
it's all like wiggling like this and I
have to get a spoon and eat out of its
stomach like that that would probably
gross me out I did grow up vegetarian so
like I was kind of scared of me and fish
and all that stuff but then the more I
started to eat sushi and the fresher the
sushi got and the more delicious it
tastes I started to have this
correlation so now when I see how fresh
that is oh my god damn that [ __ ] must be
really good
well you know according to this article
here they're saying that a lot of people
were arguing that the twitching is not a
sign of freshness if they're suggesting
that it's nothing more but a reaction
from the surviving nerves that were not
removed properly during preparation and
so is that also make an illness but it's
just rigor mortis that well rigor mortis
is when something gets stuck yeah
no no it's when you're just [ __ ] it's
like three days later when the thing
just like won't move and you could like
pick up a dead rat and it just like it's
the [ __ ] thriller move what did that
college when they twitch after they die
then I think it's the nerves just the
nerves yeah cuz you're a body part your
whole body doesn't die at the same time
sometimes your lungs die first
and then your brain start still sending
neuron signals so that still moving
around or your liver still might be like
every part shuts off that difference
that's why your dick can be alive on the
on the table even you can be and you get
a boner right yeah that happens that I'm
not even kidding that does that's
[ __ ] disgusting that crazy like you
you're dead and you have a [ __ ]
Ranger but then what if you like Jack it
off but the balls died and nothing comes
out um okay that's a really dick in the
balls can't die at different times
that's why we need a doctor here it's to
see if he would leave during the humor
that would like to sit bad yesterday at
the barbershop FA NRF AG sure what you
said oh I thought he said yesterday I
thought so I'm like we didn't know so
the other day a fan at the barbershop
he's been watching us for a long time I
was like oh when did she watch us and
goes oh when I when I was in high school
now he's a doctor so we helped them get
into Medical School
maybe he'd be done is sit in there yeah
but yeah so yeah he's doing his
residency right now it's not like a
full-on full-on but he is a doctor yeah
yes you know yeah yeah should be ever
sent to humor I mean if he likes our
[ __ ] you got to yeah if you like so [ __ ]
I was like there's some do but then I'm
gonna get a little scared so it's like
like dad comedy or patch Adams kind of
[ __ ] I mean like I put on the rubber
nose he's like oh yeah love comedy and I
like that kind of thing yeah I have a
comedy than a doctor with like some
twisted comedy and then I don't know
does like I want dr. Nick oh I like that
[ __ ] though
I want the animal doctor they can say
whatever the [ __ ] they want I know you
have such power as a doctor and
authority were in that coat like you'd
come in and be like hey you know you you
know holding somebody else's chart and
[ __ ] like all that stuff they never know
[ __ ] anyways well that's what people
think the other thing we have a doctor
here that will speak for all doctors
because one doctor here means that they
speak for the entire medical cancer they
don't even agree to tell simplified I'm
have your back here because obviously
doctors have completely different
opinions about different things yeah
that's why you need to get three four
fifth opinions that cancer is benign
[Laughter]
story there is a team that thought it'd
be funny to do a two for one kind of
deal to get into the theater to watch
black panther what's so funny about that
you'll see oh I still have a wash down
watch it well they're doing the
trenchcoat thing tall men to do
by yourself I don't get it
that's where it was right the little
rascals for Joe that's a long trench
coat then how do you get such a longest
trench coat in his arms are long too
they went to the big and tall store for
sure yeah the caption did we tried
getting the two-for-one special a black
panther the manager was not having it
it's just one seat maybe his regional
manager is a real bastard though you
never know but how much money they spent
at the big and tall store trenchcoat is
so [ __ ] long though for someone who
actually fits into that what are they
like eight feet and little average
walkway is goofy it looks longer than
eight feet the best is when it's three
kids stacked one on top of the other
it's not quite there you know did you
ever see the meme where they show you
like a dude wearing like baggy shirt
saggy baggy pants yeah let me show the
transparent image of an effect like two
or three midgets sitting on it you can't
say the word [ __ ] people it's fine if
we have a trigger warning before the
video I know that we do that now Tom
Segura made a joke about that oh you
know what else I liked about the Tom
Segura stand-up is I found out that
there is no such thing as white people
loyalty and I'm jealous funny they are
jealous of minority and he says I was
like what is this really yeah I was like
is this true white people don't there's
no white people loyal so much my heart
level well there is and that that's when
it gets scary yeah that's what it's a
tiki torch wait guys that's the white
people
you can't you can't really have it what
technically
white people they can't be loyal to each
other because it just feels like oh [ __ ]
there's oppression again or some point
that so it's kind of it kind of sucks
that even if they do what sucks they
should have like well I speak for all
white people there's a white person yeah
and I can tell you that that's not true
oh I get it
you have your backup yeah you did see
because we're I'm a white representative
yeah that's right yeah when you shoot
her voice I speak for all [ __ ] Asians
even if they don't want it that's cuz
that's what I believe in well you don't
speak for all Asian women where's the
Asian woman here I speak for all aging
women
Bart does I know lies as an Asian girl
yes I do do barton up now Bart and and
Joe do you guys ever have a different
opinion about anything never absolutely
your agent men right okay all great
because we have to completely agree
that's right or else if we don't agree
then it's like we're backstabbing the
group see that's why I don't buy all
this like okay there's there's also
Asian loyalty or whatever I know there's
a degree of it but I don't know if it's
like why don't there's there's no
there's agent Lloyd II just Chinese
people don't have loyalty that's it what
tom is trying to say though it's like if
there's a group of mixed people right
and then if like let's say some dude
talks [ __ ] to the black guy the other
black guy in the group is immediately
gonna stand up and back that guy same
thing a group of mixed people if there's
two or three Asians some guys Punk's the
asian guy yeah they're all gonna stand
up if someone talks [ __ ] to the white
guy the other white guys anybody I have
nothing to do with this because they
know if things get pushed all the way to
the extremes it's gonna end up being the
black and the Latino and the Asian
everyone's gonna team up on the two
white guys so they don't they don't ever
want it to get to that point
gotcha yeah so they're just like that
what about de-escalation yeah dad
they're on their own hands in the bed
you call it de-escalation
so that's good that's a good way to put
it yeah I I witnessed this the other day
when we were getting ice cream there was
this guy like what uh he was like bump
in some African music it was like
uber driver yeah bird right yeah I
didn't this guy was he was on his date
he's like a African kid and then like he
was like oh [ __ ] and he just starts
dancing right he goes you Nigerian man
and he's like yeah and then he's like
and then they just had this African
connection like just from the music and
he came up to the car and then he got
out of the car and they started [ __ ]
like dancing and [ __ ] and I was like
that scene in the movie yeah this is so
real
[Music]